wenn man auf schweizerdeutsch von google
sprachassistenten wissen will ob es am
donnerstag auch schneit
[Musik]
dann ist das oft ein ziemlich
aussichtsloses unterfangen
und bei der frage ob es morgen früh gibt
sagt alexa von amazon zwar ziemlich viel
aber die eigentliche frage hat auch sie
nicht verstanden jetzt hast du mich
geweckt sprachassistenten können
verdammt praktisch sein und werden
international immer beliebter auch jeder
zweite schweizer hat schon mindestens
einmal einen genutzt obwohl die
assistenten sich mit schweizerdeutsche
offensichtlich ziemlich schwer tun
an der uni luzern verstraete hofstetter
zur nutzung von sprachassistenten in der
schweiz
die ausgeprägten dialekte werden
schlechter verstanden das sind zunehmend
zum beispiel das wallis zu deutsch
ostschweizer dialekt bündner dialekt
ein problem das auch er kennt david
inseln hat vor fünf jahren ein start-up
gegründet sie programmieren hier
software zur spracherkennung für
schweizerdeutsch alexa verstehe ich das
schweizer team das schweizerdeutsche
existiert er nicht als geschriebene
sprache und wir sind auch sehr variables
hier engem raum jedes seitental hat ein
weniger in die andere aussprache das
macht das ganze set komplex und
aufwendig sie haben hier zb eine
spracherkennungssoftware für eine
fernbedienung programmiert in zig
dialekten und eine software die
wortprotokolle von parlamentsdebatten
erstellt wie bringt man einer software
eine sprache bei einerseits haben wir
aufnahmen
die laufend korrigiert werden so lernt
das system stetig hinzu dann können wir
auch auf ressourcen zurückgreifen wie
zum beispiel bücher die in mir den
dialekten verfügbar sind das zeigt es
geht werden also irgendwann auch apple
google und co schweizerdeutsch verstehen
bisher jedenfalls lohnt sich das für die
wirtschaftlich offenbar nicht und denke
je mehr schweiz solche systeme nutzen
werden desto mehr daten fallen
schlussendlich an bei den anbietern die
dann genutzt werden können mit machine
learning um sich halt besser auf die die
ja die nutzer einstellen zu können
übrigens besteht für viele
sprachassistenten auch an anderer stelle
noch nachholbedarf mit deutschen
dialekten tun sie sich ebenfalls oft
noch schwer